well today we have the privilege of
having the world-famous paleontologist
dr. Derek Riggs there's also the
director of the Peabody decison faculty
and his specialty is looking at
fossilized fauna and flora and so we are
on what we are in good hands to worry
about such a fascinating field of
paleontology so let's welcome our guest
to the podium shall we great well it's
wonderful to be in front of an audience
so early in the morning that responds
when you say good morning because I've
often talked to audiences in you say
good morning and they all write it down
which is a little bit a little bit
worried I realized this morning that I'd
made a very serious mistake when I
offered the title of this lecture
because of course if you read fantastic
fossils you automatically assume
fantastic lecture so what I should have
done was said I'd talk about
fossilization so you'd all come assuming
somebody on the podium would be pretty
fossilized and by the end of the
presentation we'll probably be totally
fossilized so whatever I said would be a
pleasant surprise and we all do my best
I hope everybody's worked out what this
this technical scientific term here
means think about it so we have some
fantastic fossils in New Haven of course
at the Peabody Museum so has everybody
here been to the museum or most people
have good and I hope you continue to go
back from time to time this is our
Torosaurus statue we've got 75 million
years down here that's not of course
the age of the statue that's the age of
the fossil that is reconstructed here
and Torosaurus happily has become a kind
of New Haven landmark now and helps
people find the Peabody this is our
Great Hall which you're all familiar
with of course our next major exhibit
opens on October the 10th and it's
called disease detectives and it's very
interactive it's about young people
learning about the diagnosis of diseases
and it also has a second exhibition with
it called solving the puzzle which is
about Lyme disease and West Nile virus
and you and we're trying to work on a
curators choice that will appear
somewhere during the run between October
and the end of January because the Yale
Daily News announced not very many weeks
ago that the Peabody has one of the 15
weirdest things at Yale I think we have
actually quite a lot more than the 15
but in this case it was our collection
of tapeworms
so we're going to put some tapeworms
outside in the curators choice and I'm
rather afraid we'd have to offer people
who come to these exhibits some kind of
counseling as they leave because
otherwise they'll be too terrified to
emerge into the outside world so come to
the Peabody after October the 10th to
see that exhibit and at the moment were
cleaning the mural so we're restoring
the mural and that will be finished more
or less by Thanksgiving so the Great
Hall you could still come along and see
the dinosaurs but the mural is a little
bit obscured but I'm confident that
it'll look really magnificent when this
job is done it will be much brighter and
any of the slight streaking and staining
will have disappeared so fantastic
fossils
these are trilobite s-- from rocks about
four hundred and sixty-five million
years old here in the United States and
by any measure this is a fantastic
specimen it has three different
individuals as you can see normally
these things are broken up
the different parts are scattered in the
sediment and to find them as complete as
this is really quite remarkable here's
another trilobite this one is a Devonian
trilobite a little bit younger 400
million years old from Morocco and it
was described in the paper where it was
first illustrated as a perfectly
preserved fake Hubbard trilobite it's
not perfectly preserved because first
art trilobite as far as we know didn't
have green eyes so this is a
mineralization phenomenon something
reflecting changes in the rock but more
importantly it's not perfectly preserved
because it only consists of the hard
outer skeleton the mineralized part of
the fossil and the soft tissues
underneath the appendages and the gut
and the musculature and so forth is not
preserved in this specimen so even
though it looks fabulous it's not by my
criteria perfectly preserved and when I
talk about fantastic fossils as you'll
see I'm interested in those soft tissues
what happens the rest of the animal and
when can that material get preserved so
to understand that we have to do a
little decay experiment so I'm sorry
those of you who've just eaten a rather
tasty doughnut and had a cup of coffee
because I'm going to show you this thing
degrade in a petri dish in the lab let
me first assure you that it was killed
completely painlessly it suffered much
less than the huge numbers of these
things that fishermen put on hooks all
around the coast of the British Isles
and I've no doubt here every weekend to
go fishing in the sea so let's watch it
decay so after two days you can see that
the rear of the animal has broken open
and most of the muscle tissue inside has
started to go to a rather unpleasant
fluid then after six days you can see
that this process is continuing there
are other breaks in the specimens and
you've got the fluid leaking out into
the pet
- after 16 days it looks even more
unpleasant very little is surviving
apart from this skin which is the outer
skin of this marine worm and also signs
of the bristles and as we'll see the
jowls and then finally after 30 days
this is essentially all you have left so
this is the jaw of the worm and then
these are the bristles I've just shown
you - here there are many many of these
all the way down the side of these
particular kinds of marine worms we call
them bristle worms for that reason so
the point I'm making here is that in a
very short time indeed most of the
information about this organism has
decayed away and were left just with the
most decay resistant parts and we ran
these things on tumbling barrels with
with bacteria at high temperatures in
the lab for as long as the research
grant lasted and they didn't decay away
so this is the stuff that's going to
normally get into the fossil record so
extraordinary preservation which is what
I'm going to talk about this morning
fantastic fossils essentially involve a
race between decay on the one hand which
is destroying information and
fossilization on the other which is
preserving it so we can demonstrate this
again by looking not at a laboratory
experiment at something much less smelly
and far more comforting and that is a
series of fossils from the famous Green
River Formation out in Wyoming these are
fish about 50 million years old and we
can show a series of course not of one
individual but of several different
fossils which show what happens when
this fish decays this is not a marine
animal by the way this lived in lakes so
here's a number of specimens of Pescara
at various stages of degradation until
finally the worst specimens look more or
less like this
so again extraordinary preservation is
about this race between fossilization on
the one hand and decay on the other can
anybody think about
might have happened to this particular
specimen Oh somebody's gonna answer me
yes it got neither smashed nor eaten but
those are both very good suggestions
what actually happened is the decay
gases inside the fish filled up on the
bottom of the lake and eventually the
thing exploded and blue bits of tissue
and the remaining skeleton around on the
lake bed so what we mean by fantastic
fossils then are the preservation of
these soft tissues the things that
aren't mineralized in life aren't hard
to use a simple term so if we think
about the earliest bird this very famous
fossil Archaeopteryx lithographic ah
which was discovered in 1860 very
shortly after the publication of
Darwin's famous Origin of Species
discovered in the Jurassic 150 million
year old rocks in Germany and includes
now just a handful or a couple of
handfuls of specimens some of which show
the impressions of feathers and they
also include the outline of a
well-preserved feather and the point
here is that without the feathers the
feather impressions this particular
animal would have been interpreted as
any old vertebrate and in in some cases
it was actually interpreted as as an
early dinosaur it turns out to be a
relative of the dinosaurs but actually a
bird so in this case the preservation of
the feathers is all-important in terms
of telling us what's going on so I have
very few of these kinds of slides so
don't get alarmed but just to give you a
little bit of background here we're
talking really about fossilization
potential and if you go to the beach and
collect organisms of course what you're
collecting are shells again the hard
parts the things that would normally get
into the fossil record and you can do a
simple survey as somebody did years ago
at Friday Harbor on the west coast and
you can look at the range of animals in
the mud and the range of animals in the
sand on the beach and the range of
animals in the rock pools and in each
case
around about 60% as an average 6 out of
10 of these things are not represented
as fossils they don't have hard parts so
this is the way of saying that most
animals out there and it applies both to
land animals and to marine animals don't
have hard parts and therefore don't
normally have a fossil record
they require fantastic preservation of
some kind or other so one of the most
famous deposits of exceptionally
preserved or fantastic fossils is the
burgess shale which is Cambrian in age
about 510 million years old out in
British Columbia and it was discovered
in 1909 by this gentleman here
Charles Walcott who at that stage was
the what he was called a secretary of
the Smithsonian Institution in those
days now we probably call him the chief
executive or the president and this is
how he dressed in the field he dressed
to go into the field seven and a half
thousand feet up in the Canadian Rockies
and he got there by horseback and he
lived in tents but he looks as if he's
about to head to church on a Sunday
morning
so unfortunately standards of dress in
the field and indeed I apologize in the
lecture theatre have significantly gone
down over the years
now these burgess shale fossils include
lots of organisms with no hard parts
here are a couple of arthropods
relatives of lobsters and shrimps and
crabs this one has a nice shell but it's
not a hard shell it's like one of those
soft shrimps and here's a reconstruction
of the fauna by an artist showing the
variety of remarkably odd-looking
animals that are preserved in this
Cambrian deposit and indicate what life
was like in the seas at the relatively
earliest stages of the origins of all
these major groups of animals now we can
do a simple experiment to just emphasize
how important these kinds of remarkable
preservations are we can take a
representative cartoon of all the
Cambrian animals in the burgess shale
I mean I can assure you that this is a
reasonable representation by no means
all of them and we can take away all the
animals in this cartoon that don't have
some kind of hardshell and this is what
we end up with so this is what
paleontologists who work on marine rocks
are normally working with they're
working with just those few groups that
happen to have hard shells the ones that
would give you the shells on the beach
and they're for this kind of fossil
record is somewhat biased and that's why
I'm particularly interested in this
exceptional record so just to flesh it
out for you here 86% of different kinds
of animals even up to 90% of individual
organisms are not normally preserved so
what you're fantastic fossils do for us
they provide evidence of the evolution
of these soft bodied animals the ones
that aren't normally preserved and they
also preserve a much more complete
picture of the range of different kinds
of animals that lived in the past so
let's think about extinct creatures for
a moment or two I want to illustrate
this with one of my favorite organisms
from this Cambrian burgess shale an
animal called opa Vania now I've
introduced you to Charles Wolcott in his
Sunday best field gear and this is one
of the plates from his early papers in
1912 and I'm good to focus on this
animal here this was the specimen he
used to describe it in the first place
and this is opa binya this is my
graduate student advisor a man called
Harry Whittington he's now in his 90s
he's just I think he published his last
paper this year so paleontology is
clearly good for you you keep going for
a long long time here he is working in a
tent this is a National Geographic
photograph working in a tent at Burgess
back in the 60s and this is his
reconstruction in 90
seventy-five of this extraordinary
animal oppa Vania well nowadays with the
internet and people's imaginations and
what we know about the fossil record
these kinds of things
barely create a ripple of interest when
he first showed this at a conference
back in the 1960s like this for example
the whole audience started laughing
because they thought this animal was
just totally bizarre and in a sense it
is bizarre in a way this is how his
reconstruction was translated into
something looking a bit more lively and
you can see it has five eyes on the head
this strange proboscis like structure
that it probably plunged into holes to
pull worms out of the seabed for food
and then this tail which looks rather
like something for stabilizing and
steering as it swam along and it
suffered a range of indignities over
time this is a reconstruction from a set
of toys produced by the Royal Ontario
Museum this is not based on any actual
evidence of the color of open binya I
think it's highly unlikely it was lit up
like a Christmas tree this is our most
recent reconstruction the details are
not important for our purposes today and
opah binya has even appeared in cartoons
over the years he's saying who's your
friend zippy and zippy is saying oh this
is opa binya he says he's from the
Precambrian of course cartoonists always
get things wrong he's actually from the
Cambrian and he says I was once
mistakenly classified as a crustacean a
kind of shrimp and opa vinius say of
course I'm not a crustacean doesn't look
like one either does he so we'll come
back to OPA binya a little bit later at
the end of the lecture so the other
thing apart from revealing these
extraordinary creatures that we would
know nothing about that fantastic
fossils do is preserve a much more
complete picture of the whole diversity
of life at different times in the past
and I'm shifting now from marine to
freshwater examples and this is a famous
deposit called the rainy church in
Scotland
and which is about 400 million years so
some 100 more million years later than
the burgess shale itself and these are
some of the earliest land dwelling
animals and they're preserved in a kind
of bog setting there wasn't much
vegetation there was vegetation but it
wasn't very complicated at that time and
this particular bog was a little bit
like Yellowstone today in that there
were there were vents exhaling various
kinds of chemicals into the water and
that assisted in the preservation of
some of the tiny little crustaceans and
plants that were living there so let's
look at one or two of these here's one
this is a kind of early spider we call
it at trigger natal bed and the neat
thing about these kinds of fossils is
that if you get the right kind of
situation you can dissolve them out of
the rock
so people have used very strong acids to
take them out of shale and when this was
first done of course there was enormous
excitement but they looked so
beautifully preserved and in some ways
rather like living organisms that people
would come into the lab in the morning
and assume that they did somehow fallen
out of the ceiling because they couldn't
possibly have been in rocks of this age
here's a reconstruction of one of these
fossil spiders they're little tiny
things just a few millimeters long and
then we can get into some spectacular
detail so because the Rhynie church is a
very hard quartz like substance and it's
also largely translucent we can shine
light through it we can actually use a
microscope to focus at different points
within the specimen and some colleagues
in Berlin have done this most recently
and I'll explain why this is interesting
in a moment or two here's a section in
the rock through one of these spider
like animals and if we look in great
detail here we can actually see
structure in the lungs of this animal so
you can section these fossils using the
microscope at intervals of
point one of a micron and you we're all
saying what what one of a micron and I'm
scratching my head there are 1000
microns in a millimeter so that means
there are about 25,000 microns in an
inch so microns are pretty fine and if
we do this we can actually look at the
structure inside the animal's lung so it
looks a little bit like this so you can
see slices through revealing the
structure and you're all saying what
that looks like a kind of gray blob on a
dreary day like today so let's show you
the reconstruction of this thing so we
can restore this and you can actually
look inside the tissues of this very
ancient spider like animal and you can
look at the structure which consists of
a series of layers connected by pillars
now you're all saying so what why should
I care about this well let me tell you
simply because this structure is
identical to the kinds of structures
that you get in many many modern
air-breathing spider like animals and
it's important to have demonstrated it
in the fossil because it actually
reveals without doubt that these things
were air-breathing as opposed to water
dwelling animals so the the specimens
have been washed into the pond and
preserved the detail is such that we can
look at the breathing structures inside
and we can say yes by this stage animals
were clearly out on land breathing air
so these are some of the first
terrestrial organisms so this is the
kind of information that this material
gives us so I starting to talk about
fossilization and of course I'm most
concerned with the fossilization of
these soft tissues so let's talk a
little bit about that if you think about
the worm again if you can bear to you'll
remember that within just a matter of a
few days the muscle tissue had gone to
some kind of gooey fluid so if we want
to preserve muscle tissue in the fossil
record before it goes to sludge we
have to do something really quite
remarkable and the preservation of
muscle tissue occurs in a number of
localities around the world and one of
the most famous is this one from Croce
I'm sorry from Cretaceous rocks in
Brazil about a hundred and ten million
years ago now this fossil is not a cigar
it's actually a fish but because it's
been cracked out of a concretion you
might say the fins have been knocked off
and occasionally you get fish from this
particular unit where you can split the
concretion and reveal the fish inside
and when you do this with fish from the
santana formation you'll notice that in
some cases let me just get rid of that
arrow in some cases you can see white
material inside the fossil fish so here
are the bones the bones of these orangie
looking structures but white material is
the fish tissue and this is what it
looks like close up so here are the ribs
and here is the material in between now
if you enjoy eating fish and chips this
is the kind of fossil to bring a smile
to your face because that's exactly what
you're looking at you're looking at the
material you would eat if you were able
to eat this cretaceous fish you'd have
to be careful to tease it out of the
bone so you didn't get something you
didn't want in your mouth so this is
fossil fish muscle and it's phosphatase
it's sorry it's fossilized in a mineral
called apatite which is a kind of
calcium phosphate so this forms on the
bed of the sea where a lot of these
carcasses will have accumulated and it's
really sourced mainly by dissolving the
skeleton and transferring the chemicals
into the muscle tissue but what's really
extraordinary about these cretaceous
fishes the muscle tissue survives at
very high magnification as well here
we're looking at a scale which is just
seven and a half microns so a fraction
of a millimeter this is the muscle
tissue preserved in these little
tiny crystallites of phosphate and this
is actually almost certainly a cell
nucleus so if we want to preserve muscle
tissue the stuff that normally decays
very quickly we have to have
circumstances where that gets replaced
by a mineral at a very early stage
within just a matter of days we can do
this in the lab normally when you talk
about fossilization you think it's a
geological process but of course if you
want to really understand it you have to
try and do it in the lab so as you can
see I like decaying things in the
laboratory I've shown you worms here's a
shrimp we set up a very complicated set
of probes which measure things like the
concentration of oxygen the proportion
of sulphate different chemicals in the
water and we were able in the laboratory
to produce mineralized muscle tissue
identical to the mineralized muscle
tissue you see up here which is from
some of those Cretaceous fish so this
kind of early fossilization of soft
tissues occurs within a matter of weeks
or a month or two so when you think
about fossilization in this case we're
not talking about a geological time
scale we're not talking about millions
of years we're talking about processes
that happen extremely early in which we
can replicate in the lab and of course
when you think about about it that has
to be the case we know how fast they
decay so if they're going to get
preserved the initial process has to be
something that happens extremely quickly
indeed so occasionally we get just the
right circumstances to preserve this
microscopic detail of very soft tissues
the other aspect of soft tissue
preservation are those more decay
resistant materials that survive as some
form of original chemical material I
don't know whether I'm doing that and if
I do I apologize so here's a leaf well
this leaf is 14 million years old it
comes from a locality called plucky ax
in Idaho and if you go there you can
break the rock with flat knives or you
know blades where you can push in with
your hands it's pretty soft stuff and
you can split it apart and reveal the
leaves and when you first reveal them on
the surface of the Shaylee material
they're actually colored and you can see
in this case this looks like a full leaf
so what people do is use very strong
acid again tease the leaf off the
surface of the shale or the mud stone we
might almost call it put it between two
layers of acetate and this is what you
see here then you can hold it up to the
light and you can see all the original
morphology of the leaf and it just looks
like an autumn leaf so that's fallen
outside today or yesterday but of course
this is an obvious thing to look at if
we were interested in how the chemistry
of the leaf changes now we're not going
to talk about leaves today I'm just
about to be ambushed you think it's me
cost
let's see how long it is before the
voice starts again we're not interested
in what we are and just didn't leaves
but I'm not going to talk about leaves
today I want to talk about animals of
course so the other issue is you know
how would things like this get preserved
in the fossil record because these again
are pretty soft they decay away fairly
quickly and if they're going to survive
we need to preserve the organic material
in some way so the way to explore this
is looking at different kinds of insects
and other sorts of creepy crawlies
arthropods in progressively older rocks
so this is an excavation we did some
years ago in Germany a locality about 25
million years old and this is my former
graduate student who's now at the
Carnegie Institution in Washington and
I'd love to tell you that he dug this
entire hole and I appeared after two
weeks and came and took a few samples
but as you can imagine we had a great
deal of help digging this hole and we
arrived mercifully at a very late stage
in the process just to take one or two
samples from the layers it's interesting
actually because there's a lava flow
overlying the sediment in this fossil
lake so we're looking at material as it
were protected by a lava flow this place
is famous for its extraordinary
preservation you'd expect that because
we're talking about it and this is one
of the most famous fossils from and
Spell it's a flying rodent or flying
mouse we know it's a rodent because we
can see its teeth at the front there and
when you get specimens that are spread
out you can see that the morphology of
the arms is correct in the sense that
the skin formed a kind of web which they
were used they jumped out of trees and
glided to the next tree and at least
this one probably failed to die to the
next tree it lied it glided into the
middle of the lake
and sadly but wonderfully for us
it turns up in the in the fossil record
so there are lots of other things
arguably less interesting but in some
ways more exciting from the chemistry
point of view in this lake including the
remains of lots of little beetles
weevils in this case and if we look at
the structure of the the outer hard
crunchy coating on the beetle under the
microscope it shows some of the original
kind of plywood structure that you see
in beetle cuticles so just two of these
diagrams so don't get alarmed how do you
analyze these things well
they don't dissolve the best way to
analyze the chemistry of anything as
many of you have already discovered is
to dissolve it and make it into a liquid
that you can then analyze in various
ways these things don't dissolve because
they're very tough very resistant and
it's why they get fossilized so to deal
with them we have to vaporize them so we
put them in a machine that heats them up
to about three hundred and degrees
centigrade in a matter of seconds and
then blasts the vapor through a mass
spectrometer and that mass spectrometer
gives us some indication of the
different compounds different chemicals
that are in the cuticle so of course how
do you interpret these when you compare
them to the cuticle of a living beetle
you go out and collect one in the woods
so here's a modern beetle and this is
the kind of trace that our mass
spectrometer produces and here's our
fossil beetle and the important point
here is that in some ways they're very
similar so this particular locality a 10
spell some 25 million years ago has
preserved a lot of the original beetle
chemistry are you gonna ask a question
um it's much better to dissolve things
if they're soluble if they can be
dissolved in the particular kinds of
chemicals that you use but this stuff
doesn't dissolve in normal chemicals
that's why it fossilizes so well so the
only way to deal with it is to heat it
up and essentially turn it into a gas
that you can pass through your
spectrometer if we go to much older
arthropod material this is about 420
million years old it's a big sea
scorpion from the Silurian of New York
State there are lots of these things up
in northern New York State
some of them getting up to you know
several feet in length this one would
have been about 10 inches and these
things are also marvelously preserved so
sometimes when you crack the rock open
the cuticle flakes up and you can peel
it off the fossil and put it into a
little glass vial and take it away and
analyze it and when we do that with
these much older arthropod materials the
chemistry is totally different so over
time these things that clearly
transformed and this is a similar kind
of process to the transformation of
organic materials into ultimately oil or
fossil fuels it's the same kind of
process well how else can we look at it
well we can look at it in amber amber is
a kind of natural laboratory here's a
beetle in amber from Dominica about 25
million years old and if you find
somebody who's kind enough to allow you
to destroy their amber insects and you
put them in liquid nitrogen
you can explode away the resin and you
can pick at various bits of the fossil
and analyze them and the neat thing
about amber is that it occurs in rocks
of different ages through the record
from resins in East Africa which are
just about 20,000 years old to these
kinds of fossils in Dominican amber
which is about 25 million to much older
ones and you see this kind of constant
transformation of the material in these
in
over time this is clearly some kind of
fossilization process that's going on
and you can also do it in the laboratory
now you can't you can't do an experiment
for 25 million years in the laboratory
unfortunately the National Science
Foundation won't give you a grant that
lasts that long so you have to do them
much more quickly than that and as some
of you young chemists will know of
course the way to get reactions to go
faster is to heat the whole thing up so
we put these specimens in what we call a
bomb and the bomb is a very thick
reinforced steel tube which is there of
course to allow you to pressurize the
experiment and stop it
exploding under high temperatures and we
did these experiments started them some
years ago with a group in non-si in
France and this group were interested in
looking at the chemistry and origin of
petroleum so you can imagine the scene
this crazy while I was then of course
based in England this crazy scientist
and one or two of his graduate students
arrived with a bunch of leaves and
beetles and cockroaches actually
cockroaches are great at least for this
kind of thing and we said can we put
these things in your bomb and he looked
at us as if we were completely mad and
as Frenchmen do he sort of shrugged
their shoulders and said ok and we did
it and it actually produced some very
exciting results because well this is
what the process looks like you put them
inside gold envelopes little tiny gold
things there's a pen to give you the
scale Gold is good because it's very
inert and doesn't affect the reaction
this is what comes out of the gold bombs
depending on what you put in but in
terms of our results we were able to
transform scorpions into something at
about 350 degrees centigrade that looks
exactly like a fossil scorpion so we
could replicate this process so what
this is telling you is that the change
in the chemistry is about the
recombination of the
different components in that animal over
a very long period of time and we've
just managed to speed it up by doing it
in the lab at very high temperatures so
we can begin to understand both the
fossilization of muscles and also the
fossilization of cuticles now finally I
want to tell you a little bit about a
new locality we've been working on which
happens to be in Herefordshire in
England and it's about 425 million years
old and it also shows you how one can
use these fantastic fossils to tell
about life in the past so here's our
mode of operating this is an ancient
volcanic ash that's been dumped in the
sea and probably reworked and has buried
various kinds of little marine animals
so in terms of collecting it's very easy
it appeals enormous ly to an Irishman
like myself because it's just like
picking up potatoes in a field so these
are our potatoes we collect them in
supermarket bags happily it's very
difficult now to get plastic supermarket
bags in England and Ireland or it's
becoming increasingly difficult because
we're trying to avoid having to recycle
them so this is what our fossil material
looks like you split it with a vise and
you get tiny little crystalline things
in the middle which turn out to be
fossils so this is our processing plant
you cut the little fossil out of the
concretion or nodule or potato if you
prefer you put it into this holder here
you turn the holder upside down and run
it on a glass plate where you've got
some grit very fine grit to polish up
the surface and you essentially grind
the specimen away so you'd grind a few
microns off turn it over
wash it photograph it put it back on the
rig grind another few microns off turn
it over wash it put it back on the rig
so a very time-consuming process to
produce a whole lot of sections
through the animal here's an example now
this is what it looks like when you
first crack the concretion well you and
I should say it's about four millimeters
long so we're talking about a fraction
of an inch quarter of an inch perhaps
what no idea what it is so if you grind
it away and then assemble the slices
this is actually what that specimen
turned out to be so this is an ancient
sea spider and sea spiders being soft
are very rare in the rock record and you
can get remarkable detail as you can see
of the the claws I'm sorry but flaws on
the head here the various appendages
these tiny little spines and you've got
to remember this thing is in total the
screen is less than half an inch long so
the details are really quite
extraordinary let me show you one other
fossil from this deposit this is a
little almost like a horseshoe crab like
thing but again just a few millimeters
long we call it a coalesce and again we
can look at the reconstruction of that
which does a little dance for us so we
can do a certain amount of animation to
show the potential movement in the
little fossil so again this is a
remarkable preservation and then finally
the importance of fantastic fossils they
increase our knowledge of extinct
creatures that we simply would know
nothing about the easiest easiest
example is if we had no fossil record
we'd have no idea there had ever been
dinosaurs but I've shown you other kinds
of animals that tell you the same story
they show you the evolutionary history
that leads to life today and of course
as we've seen they reveal the nature of
ancient communities
and of course my final message is that
at the Peabody Museum every day he is a
and you can work that out for yourselves
and then I'm going to insert a little
video that will show you a little bit
more about that
extraordinary animal OPA binya and let
me see if I can get that to behave now
okay yes you can abort